But invading the prefectures and what's not behind it.
1 call to violence We remember the yellow vests at the English well,
uh,
who set fire to this prefecture,
there could have been deaths This is social self-defense,
popular self-defense.
We can't have one people,
workers,
employees,
working people who today are forced to tighten their
belts like never before and not die.
We can't continue to have a government with absent subscribers on this subject.
And so I say it again if the government takes uh provisions,
obviously the situation would be different.
Today,
the government is doing nothing.
We have a minister of the economy who spends his time asking,
asking the boss to increase wages,
asking the oil company not to increase the
price of gasoline at any given moment.
We need people who decide.
..
The role of government is to decide and until they decide,
of course we need to defend ourselves.
And this includes the initiatives proposed by Fabien Roussel.